I don't want to seem over
dramatic
ail listen I was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of a B25
Mitchell paneto aircraft a for me don't
sass me and I went to this website and
this ad popped up that said Hey Ron
Swanson check out this great
offer what's your question my question
is what the hell like how do they know
who you are yeah okay um there are these
things called cookies where like if you
go to a site and buy something it'll
remember you and then create ads for
other stuff you might want to buy so it
learns information about me seems like
an invasion of privacy dude if you think
that's bad go to Google Earth and type
in your
address
Indianapolis is home to Charles
Mulligan's Steakhouse the best damn
Steakhouse in the damn State let's go
nope oh my God they they just forgot to
unlock the door that's
all Ron it looks like they're closed
some kind of health code
violation Ron stop it
Ron they just boarded her up like she
was some common
Warehouse I should have been here what
happened to the stakes that were in
there when they
closed do you think they got eaten why
don't we go back to my place and I'll
fire up the grill you sure you're not
expecting company or something
no you say Ron go back to my place and
make you some grub it'll be just as good
as it would have been
here okay call me let me know where you
are and if you
have Ron what in the devil's name is
this portella of mushrooms where's the
Steak oh there's no steak that's a
healthier option it's organically
grown you okay whoo whoo wo okay can you
get us a cold compress or something we
did surgery just like you taught us okay
you know what why don't you girls clean
up all this hair and I'm going to talk
to Ron let's cut off our toes no let's
not I'm going to take this bag too you
need to fix this it's not that bad
nobody got hurt it's extremely bad I
love this woman and I just want to show
her that I'm capable of watching her
children without something horrible
happening what did you just say you love
Diane no I did not yes you did that is
so cute for God's sake Hansen will you
please focus on the larger
problem
mommy
girls girls I don't know what you think
you heard but please don't tell your
mother what you incorrectly think you
heard R loves
Mommy momy I love nothing what the
shrim okay rethink that move
son
so who broke
it I'm not mad I just want to
know I did I broke no you didn't Tom
don't look at me look at Ben what I
didn't break it huh that's weird how'
you even know it was broken because it's
sitting right in front of us and it's
broken suspicious no it's not if it
matters probably not but April was the
last one to use liar I don't even drink
that crap oh really then what were you
doing by the coffee cart earlier I used
the wooden stirs to push back my
cuticles everyone knows thater okay
let's not fight I broke it let me pay
for it run no who broke
it
Ron Don has been awfully quiet really
yeah
really I broke it it burned my hand so I
punched
it ladies
ladies
there must be a way out of here I don't
think there is they installed these
magnetic locks 2 years ago there's no
way around them yes yes there is I'll
simply punch my fist through a window
Ron there's security wire in there
you'll slice your arm open I would
rather bleed out than sit here and talk
about my feelings for 10 hours I'm
hungry okay well don't be such a baby I
cooked you some bacon for a trail snack
I ate it already what I could smell it
in your purse before I even parked my
car and now it's gone and I Hate
Everything Ron can I have a burger I'm
hungry for the last time no Burger yet
I've got ribs and I've got beef cheek
Ron where are my vegan soy patties oh I
gave them to the kids they love them
they're skipping them across the pond
Donna I got to go to the boys's room can
I have a ride in your car absolutely not
this barbecue stinks I'm saying it it
stinks do you have any plates or
anything I mean how are we supposed to
eat these rumps Ron if no one takes me
to the bathroom I'm just going to have
to go in the trees all
right forget it you have ruined a
perfectly good barbecue with your
demands and
chatter
enjoy the rest of your
evening hi there what's going on here
puppy puppy is here can we keep him my
neighbor's dog had a litter they're
looking for people to adopt I love him I
wish he had tiny puppy shoes I would
totally shine his little shoes for free
a I do say the cutest stuff look I love
a good dog as much as the guy but this
building doesn't allow animals Andy take
him outside and shoot him no just keep
him outside oh come on Ron I'm just a
little puppy I ain't done nothing wrong
I'm just a
puppy I like your mustache I wish I
could have one but I can't cuz I'm just
a little
puppy okay take him out and shoot him oh
my God oh
my got your hat Ron I have your hat oh
my God are you in a lot of pain I was
shot in the head with a shotgun Ron it's
actually not that serious I just need
you to stay calm okay yeah I'm I'm just
going to stay angry I find that relaxes
me we need that picture for privacy
reasons okay but I don't know how
anybody would know it's you we followed
your
instructions that's too much information
okay all public photos of me recovered
name plate removed from my office door
pediatrician files
confiscated and destroyed anything I'm
missing great news Ron John ralphio
loves your shirt what the hell are you
talking about oh I've been taking
pictures of you all day from my new
Facebook album Ron Swan getting off the
grid Tom do you maybe see a problem with
what you've
done I do now yes
sorry
erase erase erase erase all pictures of
Ron erase all pictures of
Ron erase all pictures of Ron what the
hell is happening I think he
accidentally opened up Vine you just
vined your first selfie Ron and I'm
Vining you Vine your selfie the world is
a
nightmare pictures of
Ras all pictures of Ron erase all
pictures of
r no f me just one second now run hey
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa run run run run
run run what's going on my ex-wife Tammy
is back yeah I saw her in the courtyard
no my other ex-wife Tammy Tammy one I
have AC crewed 228 personal days
starting right now I'm using all of
them while I'm gone you're in
[Music]
charge also I keep a sizable supply of
ground chuck in my desk remove it or it
will begin to smell God's
speed
move okay how are you feeling how are
you feeling are you dizzy dizzy are you
lightheaded when I look at my palm I see
a lady's mouth French kissing a dog is
that normal is that normal well the pain
medication I gave you is pretty strong
Donnie uses it for menstral cramps how
many did you take seven eight but wash
them down with plenty of fluids no Ron
you cannot drink Scotch with this you're
going to need to purge right now okay no
oh yeah no I'm not wasting 20 years
Scott can you open his mouth Leslie what
open his mouth no open his mouth okay
I'm not making myself throw oh Ron I'm
sorry we have to do this this is for
your own good bite you open your mouth
listen get grab his mustache open your
mouth his chest down open your mouth his
shoulders well good news is R is resting
comfortably
that